pour que attrape une minute, attends en solo
et comme l'examen de Siri, attends
tant de fudge-ups F Colo
attend ce moment depuis longtemps
même Paul dit souffrir non merci le
commerce de détail a chuté ces dernières années F
a été une coquille  de qui elle était, elle est
convaincue que ses implants mammaires la
rendent malade,
oui, je ne peux pas avec une partie de la physique d'un pays pauvre,
alors Mamata, s'il vous plaît, descendez des bœufs
onze jublia mariage avec moi le Fertile
Gansey Manor, elle ne le cachera absolument pas,
alors F dit  au revoir à sa mère alors qu'elle
part pour la salle d'opération
un chirurgien américain est prêt à retirer
ses implants
Simone quant au dr.  Ian Satin Delta G ils
ont 30 40 50 ou 20 ans un
travailleur social une maquilleuse des femmes d'affaires une
championne du fitness comme des centaines de
Canadiennes elles disent que leurs
implants mammaires les ont rendues malades alors que leurs
médecins et Santé Canada les ont fait
croire qu'elles étaient en sécurité
en 1889 un chirurgien téméraire injecte de la
paraffine dans les seins de ses patientes
depuis que les
femmes ont été utilisées comme cobayes pour
toutes sortes d'expériences pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale une poitrine généreuse devient
un standard de beauté dans les années 40 on injecte un mélange de
graisse et de silicone  directement dans
les seins de la femme dans les années 50 qui ont été
remplacés par des éponges en plastique, les médecins ont même
essayé des voyages de polymères avec des résultats désastreux
en 1962 Timmy gene Lindsey, une mère américaine,
est la première femme à recevoir un
implant en silicone similaire à celui que l'on voit
aujourd'hui
peu de temps après l'invention des implants salins.
la coque est également en
silicone mais ils sont remplis d'une
solution stérile 50 ans et des milliers
de chirurgies plus tard le safet  y des
implants mammaires est toujours controversée
Katherine Claire mo bestia est l'une des
pionnières au Québec en matière d'
entraînement physique et de saines habitudes de vie la
championne de bikini fitness a des
implants mammaires depuis trois ans trois ans trop
de symptômes que beaucoup de femmes avec
des implants mammaires comme Julie connaissent trop
bien
Sumerian métalliquement fait chaque saut
Italie à peu près les films sont un phénomène
chanson de leptine est venu un poète une goutte totale
parmi les chefs d'accusation illégalement sur le temps un
défaut moi - pour la dépression Rock City
- donc Nabu mrs.  o m'a appris faisable si
ce n'est pas Java pur le diagnostic de Romano
- faire du lait un total de kia
sportage amiibo paralysie ou C G sont
évalués à la framboise panneau généralement assez rapide
Ziza une étape de fatigue plus des
acides calif ils ne sont pas sur l'épuisement c'est
là ça reste venteux  carte complète Julie
ajoute des implants en silicone F et
des implants salins chatons les trois femmes sont
convaincues qu'elles avaient une
maladie des implants mammaires une condition dont leur chirurgien ne leur a
jamais parlé non dans la muqueuse idli
design à la mode ouais problème de bienvenue
vous avez un
groupe Scecina la playa à haut risque à peu  enfant par
types de particule est la maladie de
l'immunité il a tué un flamand possède
le gros sig extrême étape ou une
maladie des implants mammaires à puissance unique n'est pas
officiellement reconnue même si
on en parle depuis 30 ans
dans les années 90 des histoires comme celles-là  de Julie
Heaven Captain a conduit à un moratoire sur
les implants en silicone et à deux énormes
recours collectifs contre les
fabricants en elle un procureur sur
A  pollo l'hôtel ci-dessus à wada Kaaba
les symptômes d'hier étaient à peu près les mêmes
que ceux que nous voyons aujourd'hui
Nasri mal sur un soutien-gorge mensuel vers le bas Ibrahim
Adan do et face à ce problème les
médecins semblent aussi impuissants aujourd'hui qu'ils l'
étaient dans le passé les occasions de péché l'écologie
considérée comme une attaque  Mme.  Palsey shitty
savant étranger mémo défectueux Malaisie
moi Patsy Massimo seconde agnostique la
dépression mesure P régime faible en gras et
fam dalla Karen le dit aussi Lexi
ASEAN
pour deux
l'alarme a sonné sur Internet c'est une
cache Thomas Tallis a dit le Danakil d'
abord un site facebook  dans révélation
rivet medusa solution à moi saint oncle
Eric écoutez Tom monsieur écoutez la Nicole
daruka Nicole de rue de est de la Colombie-
Britannique elle aussi était très malade avant de se
faire enlever ses implants en silicone
depuis trois ans c'est devenu sa
mission de sensibiliser a
maladie des implants mammaires son groupe Facebook privé
compte plus de 50 000 membres
il y a des centaines d'histoires et de liens
vers des études qui suggèrent que les implants mammaires
sont loin d'être inoffensifs Commande SATA
paniqué oh mon dieu pour mon visage sur l'application V
sur la téléphonie mobile le Clipper 2p6
profileur privé  elf Alamosa le retrait
des implants posés pour des raisons esthétiques
n'est généralement pas pris en charge par l'
assurance maladie
selon  g à notre recherche une explantation
effectuée dans une clinique privée peut coûter
entre quatre mille et douze
mille dollars
[Musique]
j'ai choisi de la faire opérer dans l'
Ohio aux États-Unis ça lui
coûtera treize mille dollars canadiens je
pourquoi l'Ohio parce que c'est  où vous trouvez le
chirurgien traînant Fang réputé
aux États-Unis pour retirer les implants
c'est là que la bande informatique s'attache la veille de la
chirurgie dr.  Fang passe près de
deux heures avec un appalamma
mécontentement hypernatrémie château un
chirurgien s kotappa de Foix kiya gauche est un
plan des entités cosmiques un plans d'un célèbre
un canal de 40 centimètres de puissance utiliser un plan
Okemah
Oakland map a demandé une géométrie Mahadevan
a des produits incroyables superbe offre ultra
maxes Emilio
avocats est sur la table d'opération depuis
une heure lorsque nous sommes autorisés à entrer dans la
salle, nous verrons bientôt par nous-mêmes à quel point
une procédure expliquée est délicate,
c'est donc la très grande capsule dr.  Liu
Jian Feng a déjà retiré un
implant il est recouvert d'une capsule une
enveloppe de tissu cicatriciel formée en
réaction à l'implant c'est beaucoup
plus épais ici c'est juste sur la
paroi thoracique chez certains patients les capsules
rétrécissent avec le temps et les seins deviennent
durs  et les capsules de F douloureuses sont encore
souples mais elles sont attachées aux
muscles et à la cage thoracique
oui oui c'est pourquoi je pense qu'elle
a ces épisodes où la poitrine fait mal
elle se sentira beaucoup mieux
le chirurgien pense que le tissu cicatriciel a
empêché EV de respirer  librement, cela
peut avoir contribué à sa fatigue et à son
anxiété,
elle pense que la toux chronique moyenne peut
également avoir été causée par le tissu cicatriciel
souvent lorsque votre respiration n'est pas
très douce, l'un de vos mécanismes consiste à
tousser, donc certaines personnes ont une toux chronique,
alors ce que nous essayons  faire est dr.  Frank a
effectué des centaines de retraits et ce
qu'elle a vu comme l'a convaincue qu'elle devait
arrêter de les mettre quand j'ai réalisé
qu'il y a une vraie maladie associée
aux implants mammaires,
vous ne pouvez pas continuer éthiquement à mettre des
implants dans sa position dérange certains
collègues à
quel point  êtes-vous perçu par les autres chirurgiens comme
un paria l'opération est terminée F une fois
les implants envoyés au Canada pour analyse le
chimiste PLA a 80 ans il a
consacré une grande partie de sa vie à dénoncer
les risques associés aux
implants mammaires à la fin des années 80 il était
conseiller scientifique  à Santé et Bien-être social
Canada, le prédécesseur de Santé Canada
à l'époque, certains implants étaient recouverts
d'une couche de polyuréthane qui s'est
brisée dans le corps du porteur.
non
seulement ses supérieurs n'ont pas écouté, mais
ils lui ont ordonné de détruire tous les
documents dans lesquels vous faisiez référence aux
dangers potentiels  des implants qu'il a refusés
et a été licencié pour insubordination après
14 ans de service quelques années plus tard
ces implants contre lesquels PLA nous mettait en garde
ont été retirés du marché depuis
lors le chimiste a fondé une société
spécialisée dans l'analyse des
dispositifs médicaux défectueux madame Guo Lao
même  culs personnels sur Apollo il existe
deux types d'implants tous deux ont des
enveloppes en silicone certains sont remplis de
gel de silicone tandis que d'autres sont remplis de
solution saline c'est le type d'implant
que j'ai depuis cinq ans survivant des
transfuges d'un cadeau comme un spa sauna
Zeppelin  fait un trémolo les vœux
de remplissage des deux implants de F n'étaient pas
étanches la solution saline pouvait s'écouler et
laisser les fluides corporels entrer cette défaillance
peut entraîner une contamination de l'implant pendant 20
ans deux chimistes ont vu toute la
contamination comme celle-ci cependant est rare
EV a été épargné
latarian un polluant sur quantum Eenie
c'est un certain lien montre Piscotty Rama
madame Colo c'est beaucoup female avec la
pierre B  lair est en train d'analyser les
capsules il découvre une anomalie sur la
bonne capsule allez petit truc ups un
rapport complet comme le quoi Julie a aussi demandé à
ple d'analyser ses implants
elle avait des implants en silicone depuis 11 ans
Pierre Blair a trouvé un trou dans l'
enveloppe d'un  des implants la
playa de mesa ce soir selon le
chimiste de l'huile de silicone s'était échappée
de l'implant de Julie depuis des années PLA n'est
pas médecin mais il est convaincu
que ce qu'il a trouvé a pu perturber
le système immunitaire d'eV et de Julie ce qui pourrait
expliquer certains de leurs symptômes  Pourtant, en
2006, lorsque Santé Canada a levé le
moratoire et les implants en silicone, il a
fait valoir qu'à l'exception de certaines
complications locales, les nouveaux
implants étaient sans danger pour la santé.
hé
nous essayons de voir ce qu'il faut pour
casser de manière agressive tous les efforts ont été faits
pour convaincre les clients des nouveaux implants
étaient indestructibles
les démonstrations étaient absurdes ouais
le système immunitaire est beaucoup plus intelligent que
ce marteau dans le corps le
système immunitaire va attaquer l'
implant mammaire et ensuite l'implant mammaire
affaiblit dr.  Yan William Cohen Thurbert
est un chercheur de renommée mondiale, le
rhumatologue est spécialisé dans les
problèmes de santé liés aux implants en
silicone. Les silicones de ces implants mammaires
peuvent
pénétrer dans les ganglions lymphatiques, puis
activer le système immunitaire et si vous
avez une activation persistante de votre
système immunitaire qui peut entraîner  à l'immunodéficience allergique,
ce qui signifie que vous n'avez pas
assez d'anticorps externes pour éliminer les
bactéries, par exemple, de sorte que vous avez
des infections récurrentes
en ce qui concerne le silicium, tous les médecins ne sont pas d'
accord sur la toxicité du widget contre la toux pour s'assurer que
le système exact là-dedans oh oui monsieur ça
va  prouver un certificat ouais et pour
le président de l'Association des
chirurgiens plasticiens et esthétiques du Québec la
maladie des implants mammaires n'existe pas la
maladie des implants mammaires a affecté le cancer de
ce dont nous parlons associé une firme une légende en
arrière sur celle sur l'associé était une
famille c'est vrai  qu'aucun lien de causalité n'a
été établi scientifiquement entre
les symptômes des femmes et leur implantation  ts mais
comme l'indique la FDA, pour exclure ce
lien des études en cours, il faudrait être
beaucoup plus large et plus long que ce qui a
été fait jusqu'à présent.
devenir dollar cut King non seulement dans
un concours public social jusqu'à ce que ces
études soient terminées
dr.  Le pervers de Cohen a sa propre
observation de ce qui se passe après le
retrait de l'implant, nous avons fait une grande
méta-analyse à ce sujet et nous avons montré
qu'environ 60 à 70% des patientes se
sentaient beaucoup mieux après le retrait de l'
implant mammaire,
donc c'est convaincant Merci Marcia
et ces  sont des rires de puces, c'est un
engagement mon caucus uniquement des revenus
Monsanto Mizoram travaille et la Santa sur
Google pourrait dire à naswa fentons
depuis que la paire a terminé ma mission est que je suis un
revenu cinq mois après l'exploitation
de toujours en difficulté l'horloge est
associée à l'argent de Silva passe mon préféré à
propos  la pizza super pour animaux de compagnie avec
respiration écologique est plus facile les problèmes de mémoire l'
anxiété et les sentiments dépressifs ont
presque disparu mais certaines douleurs et fatigue
persistent ce qui est arrivé à l'homme de torture donc
la présence d'autres maladies plus cool
des implants mammaires impériaux est toujours
controversée mais en 2016 l'
Organisation mondiale de la santé  reconnu qu'un
type d'implant peut causer le cancer du
système immunitaire un cancer qui peut nous aider
b  Pour mieux comprendre la maladie mystérieuse
de certains porteurs d'implants aujourd'hui, il n'y a
pas de débats J'ai un cancer d'origine humaine
non loin des rives du lac
Nipissing à North Bay Ontario nous avons rencontré une
femme dont la détermination est remarquable
en 2009 teri McGregor avait 44 ans lorsqu'elle a
décidé de  aller pour une augmentation mammaire
j'étais très particulier sur la taille
j'étais très particulier sur ce que mon Oke je
voulais que mon résultat soit simplement
pour restaurer les seins de mon enfant libre
c'est c'est ce que je cherchais
Terry est au coin d'une entreprise de pavage elle
se considère en parfaite santé
je ne manquais pas d'estime de soi j'ai fait cela
bien qu'invasif pas différent de ce que je
choisirais de colorer mes cheveux gris Terry
dit que son chirurgien a recommandé des
implants en silicone à surface texturée ils sont
conçus pour empêcher le durcissement des
capsules
elle dit qu'il  a parlé de certains risques,
le risque, il m'a dit
qu'il s'agissait d'une intervention chirurgicale majeure en ce qui concerne le fait d'
être sous anesthésie, puis toute
intervention chirurgicale sous  l'anesthésie comporte un
degré de risque qu'en est-il du risque
lié aux implants il n'y a pas
eu de discussion sur le risque des implants
non rien tout va bien depuis six
ans à part quelques changements subtils
je regardais des photos de moi en
pensant à ce qui ne va pas avec mon  visage pourquoi
ai-je l'air si gonflé parce que je n'avais pas
pris de poids je crois aujourd'hui je
ne sais pas pour un fait je crois aujourd'hui
que c'est quand une sorte d'
inflammation chronique a commencé une sorte d'
auto-immune vous savez alors que mon corps
réagit à  ces implants en 2015 à
50 ans Terry passe une première
mammographie de routine environ une semaine plus tard, j'ai étreint mon
mari et j'ai en quelque sorte senti un pincement dans une
traction et j'ai sauté en arrière et j'avais des
bosses très dures comme des bosses sous
ma gauche à côté  mon sein gauche
la mammographie éclate les deux implants Terry a
besoin d'une chirurgie de remplacement quand ils
m'ont ouvert j'ai en fait eu une
rupture intercapsulaire du côté droit
j'ai eu une atteinte des ganglions lymphatiques du côté gauche
et un ca supplémentaire  rupture psulaire, ce qui
signifie que le gel ressemble à de la gelée
et qu'il se trouve maintenant à l'intérieur de la cavité mammaire
et qu'il doit être nettoyé
quelques semaines plus tard, le rapport de pathologie
arrive et la vie de Theory se déroule,
il y a trois tumeurs de trois
centimètres sur cinq chacune et  donc mon
diagnostic était à un point où vous pouvez
voir visuellement le cancer Terry est le
12e Canadien avec des implants qui a reçu
un diagnostic de
lymphome anaplasique à grandes cellules associé à un implant mammaire à l'
été 2015 seulement cent quarante
cas ont été identifiés dans le monde nous savions
très bien  peu à propos de ce cancer, je suis sur les
sites Web canadiens sur le cancer. Les associations canadiennes du cancer
disent que vous savez que nous n'avons jamais
entendu parler de votre cancer. Il n'y a aucune
information là-bas.
des implants à la
capsule des ganglions lymphatiques, puis avait
métastasé aux ganglions lymphatiques de mon
abdomen et causait maintenant une détérioration des organes  ge
dans les ganglions lymphatiques de mon estomac
malgré huit traitements de chimiothérapie,
le cancer progresse toujours on dit à teri qu'il ne
lui reste plus que quelques mois à
vivre,
donc à ce moment-là, je tendais la main
dans le monde entier, je tendais la
main sur Facebook Terry rejoint un  groupe de
femmes luttant contre le même cancer grâce à
leurs contacts, elle découvre un
traitement expérimental qui
lui sauvera la vie
vous
connaissez les premières femmes qui en sont mortes,
vous savez que le diagnostic a été à peine
inventé puisque sa théorie du rétablissement
s'est engagée à aider d'autres femmes
pendant deux ans, elle a fait une tonne de
recherches, je pense que l'information la plus dévastatrice
que j'ai apprise
après avoir  est tombée malade, c'est qu'en 2006, Santé
Canada les avait remis sur le marché
avec une étude portant sur moins d'un millier de
femmes, non seulement les études d'innocuité
présentées par le fabricant  Les professeurs mentor
et Allergan ont impliqué un petit échantillon de
femmes mais elles n'étaient pas terminées elles
étaient censées durer dix ans la plus
avancée n'en était qu'à sa quatrième année
déjà leurs résultats étaient troublants les
taux de réopération étaient élevés 24
pour cent pour les patientes ayant subi une augmentation mammaire
et 41  pour cent pour ceux qui avaient
subi une reconstruction mammaire à cause
d'un cancer par exemple si j'avais su que
j'étais un cobaye et qu'à long terme la
sécurité et l'efficacité n'étaient pas faites, il n'y
avait absolument aucun moyen que j'aurais eu des
implants mammaires en
silicone ont  vendus
depuis 40 ans, mais les entreprises n'ont
fourni que deux ou trois ans de données au maximum
en 2005, l'épidémiologiste américaine
Diana Zukerman s'est battue pour empêcher le
retour des implants en silicone sur le
marché
si ces implants sont si sûrs, pourquoi
les entreprises ne le prouvent-elles pas en  étudiant les femmes
qui en avaient depuis longtemps lorsque la
FDA et Santé Canada ont donné le
feu vert aux fabricants Diana Zukerman a
perdu l'un des  les batailles les plus importantes
de sa carrière vous savez j'ai été dévastée
vraiment je pensais que cela ne pouvait pas
arriver en 2006 Santé Canada a
reconnu jhalak de données à long terme
le ministère a donné une approbation conditionnelle
aux fabricants Allergan et le mentor
ont dû entreprendre des études approfondies dont ils
étaient tenus  suivre 40 000 femmes
chacune pendant 10 ans, c'était énorme
et cela aurait été formidable si elles l'avaient
réellement fait, mais les études n'étaient
jamais terminées deux ans après le début de
son étude, Allergan avait perdu la trace de 40%
des participantes. le mentor a fait pire après
trois  années, le fabricant avait perdu la
trace de 80% des participants au lieu de
réprimer la FDA et Santé Canada a
permis aux fabricants de poursuivre
des études plus petites, une opportunité importante
qui aurait pu enfin faire la lumière sur
la maladie des implants mammaires avait été perdue, donc l'
un de mes défis à la santé  Le Canada est la
raison pour laquelle vous n'obligez pas le fabricant
à ces études à long terme parce que vous
nous avez donné une idée de  sécurité et sûreté
c'est faux
Santé Canada a refusé de nous accorder une
entrevue dans une déclaration écrite le
Ministère estime que les fabricants
ont rempli leur condition parce
qu'ils ont fait des efforts et que la
participation des femmes
échappe à leur contrôle pour le moment
Santé Canada n'entend pas exiger
le retrait des implants texturés
du marché le ministère estime
qu'un seul porteur d'implants texturés
sur 12 000 développera un lymphome à ce jour
25 femmes canadiennes ont développé ce
cancer un total de 615 cas ont été
signalés dans le monde 16 femmes sont décédées dans
un hôtel de Washington 20 femmes  se
préparent à rencontrer des responsables de la FDA et
je représente le groupe Carolina pour BIA
J'étais 11 ans au Texas et la troisième
génération de ma famille à être blessée par
mes implants mammaires J'ai reçu un diagnostic de
cancer du sein à l'âge de 33 ans et j'ai été
diagnostiqué  avec un cancer d'origine humaine appelé
lymphome anaplasique à grandes cellules à l'
âge de 40 ans j'ai perdu ma poitrine j'ai  pas
perdu ma voix
Terry McGregor a fait le voyage de
North Bay en Ontario
Nicole Neruda est arrivée de Vancouver
elle parlera au nom des 50 000
membres du groupe facebook "maladie des implants mammaires
" c'est la première fois qu'ils
déménagent les femmes ont trouvé un allié cet
ordinateur  Un analyste a découvert que
des informations cruciales sur les
implants mammaires ont été cachées au public pendant des
années, donc je m'appelle Maryse Tom. J'avais l'habitude
de travailler à la FDA et j'étais un informaticien.
tous les
rapports d'événements indésirables liés aux
implants médicaux un événement indésirable est un problème
qui met la santé d'un patient en
danger
en 2016 un avocat a demandé à Tom de l'aider
et il connaissait un certain nombre de cas
avec un type spécifique d'implant mammaire
et voulait  moi pour lui remonter les rapports
et les rapports n'étaient pas là
elle pense que les fabricants ont signalé
des incidents majeurs tels que des ruptures ou des
reo  opération dans les rapports destinés à des
incidents mineurs ces rapports ne sont pas publics
cet avocat je vais parler au
fabricant parler à la FDA et puis
tout à coup dans environ trois mois, nous
avons vu des centaines et des centaines de
rapports chaque mois la FDA a
exigé que les événements indésirables majeurs  être
correctement signalés et les statistiques du jour au lendemain
ont explosé depuis 2008 la FDA
avait publié en moyenne 230 rapports
par an liés à des
problèmes d'implants mammaires contre près de 13 000 en
2017 et au premier semestre 2018
selon nos informations certains de
ces rapports pourraient être liés à  une fraude
perpétrée par deux médecins même en
tenant compte de ce nombre, il
n'en reste pas moins que le nombre de rapports
reçus par la FDA est passé de
20 à 400 par mois et il est donc apparu
pendant peut-être 10 12 ans que les appareils
qui sont devenus plus sûrs  temps mais
vraiment c'était juste qu'ils n'étaient pas visibles au
Canada les données racontent une histoire similaire
pratiquement aucun mouvement pendant des années puis en
2017 et  18 près de 600 rapports apparaissent soudainement.
santé canada a expliqué que l'
augmentation était due à un changement dans
les pratiques de déclaration des événements indésirables des mentors
malgré l'augmentation du nombre de rapports.
médecins à la suite de
nombreux problèmes ne sont pas signalés
à la FDA il y a eu un audit effectué par
le bureau de l'inspecteur général en
2010 et ils ont constaté que seulement 14%
des événements indésirables sont signalés
nous avons montré des baignoires à matelas les
statistiques canadiennes auxquelles
il ressemble  Le Canada signale une perte
Santé Canada explique que la sous-
déclaration des événements indésirables est un
problème connu et chronique afin d'améliorer
la situation le ministère a l'intention de
rendre la déclaration obligatoire pour les hôpitaux
les nouvelles règles pourraient être en place
dès 2019 cela ne changera pas grand-chose  en ce
qui concerne les implants mammaires, la majorité des
procédures sont effectuées en cabinet privé
et non dans les hôpitaux su  les rgeons
pourront continuer à ne pas déclarer les
incidents et symptômes graves liés à la
maladie des implants mammaires c'est là le nœud
du problème à mon avis ils ont refusé
de reconnaître les symptômes ils ne les
enregistrent pas dans votre dossier
même quand les femmes explantent elles disent des choses
comme oh elle était juste mécontente de ses
implants mammaires ils écrivent que comment savez-
vous que je sais qu'en parlant d'
entendre l'histoire de 50 000 femmes 50 000
femmes sur un groupe Facebook n'impressionne pas le
dr.  Eric Bensimon pourquoi on
about prophet who vada pav a pathétique
Asda media dit you pathétique OHS alors
ils nourrissent ces somatisation le
chaton de masse si un canoë que Pascal Casa de
tete sur osipov rappelle Omo une
limousine car tant est sur le
terrorisme purusa à fils de savoir  la pathologie
le problème
dr.  Bensimon n'est pas le seul chirurgien à
penser que la maladie des implants mammaires survient d'
abord entre les oreilles avec une caméra cachée,
nos collègues sont allés acheter des
implants avec les chirurgiens EV et Catherine
et Danica vient le costume de fantaisie jouant
une mélodie enjouée, il ne faut pas longtemps pour que
Marcy entre  espace pour la collecte ajouter
qu'un patsy a sh t correspond à la maladie
égale à l'épicentre doux tous les
souvenirs que vous savez AB AC développer en
commande atomique NFC avez-vous confirmé pour
le parc est un chat mort montre venir sur nos
murs ou laisser  les villes de passage traversent
lorsque nous avons confronté dr.  Sanyal avec ce
qu'il a dit, il a insisté pour donner plus d'
informations Oh Paul Nassif les choses à
Citarella Tioga ont retardé la nociception des
excuses se produisent lena sur le stimulus
négatif tuant Ali mati comme la peinture
avec l'aimable autorisation du Don même malaisie avons-nous
localisé Z la mission de surveillance au travail d'
accord Victor étaient  développer en nature en
marche grincheuse ce qui ne nous a pas encore été expliqué
e et d'autres besoins étaient le développer sur
le même ton si la nociception est un risque
faut-il le mentionner avant l'
implantation Baskerville devoir ne peut-
elle pas prédire on a X est maintenant un comme R
et cetera  Risque de référencement du concert de Madonna comme
pour dr.  Tracy Thompson, elle nous a dit qu'elle avait
commencé à inclure le risque de maladies auto-
immunes dans nos consultations,
elle sympathise avec les femmes qui
présentent des symptômes koskoff Eric Lapham
du même Tom peut-elle kiona repo
janeski et une mélodie très opportune écoutez tous
respectueux est sur votre chemin en tant que  passkey
foo sur elle, elle devrait passer avant que
les
rapports d'éducation ne vous appellent kidnapper un peu
spécial atteindre la maîtrise au milieu de la
livre sterling la capacité de physiologie hein sens
ou la physiologie est si je voyais la spécialité
de détail en moins d'une heure ces
femmes seront à la FDA  à chaque trimestre,
ils demanderont des audiences publiques sur les
implants mammaires et le retrait des
implants texturés du marché ceux qui sont
associés à des cas connus de lymphome
avez-vous déjà eu l'occasion de rencontrer
Santé Canada, mais vous savez que nous n'avons pas
réussi à obtenir un visage  -réunion face à face
malgré que c'est toujours ainsi que je termine
chaque conversation pouvons-nous venir à Ottawa
il y a quelque chose d'intrinsèquement mal
que vous h  ave ces deux Canadiens qui
sont des défenseurs mondiaux si bruyants et pourtant
Santé Canada a fait un excellent travail
pour nous décourager, nous voulons juste une réunion,
n'ayez pas peur, je ne sais pas ce
qu'ils ont peur de
la rencontre avec les responsables de la FDA.  sur
chacune des 20 femmes a eu quelques minutes
pour présenter son histoire et ce qu'elle espère que
l'agence fera ensuite,
il y avait 20 membres de la FDA, donc j'ai
pensé que c'était fantastique qu'ils aient en
quelque sorte amené un personnel pour correspondre à l'
équilibre des femmes  qui y a assisté, nous avons
fait des centaines d'heures de travail pour elle
pour la FDA Je vais faire une coupe rapide et
éditer l'insertion de la FDA de sortie Santé Canada
Santé Canada est simplement une copie de l'
approbation conditionnelle de la FDA, il n'y a
rien qui ait été dit ici aujourd'hui qui
ne pouvait pas simplement être traduit à Santé
Canada au cours des deux dernières années, terry a
fait pression sur Santé Canada pour qu'il envoie un
avertissement à toutes les femmes qui ont des
implants texturés pouvant causer un lymphome Je conduis
une Chevy et quand mon camion reçoit une
sorte d'avertissement ou  ale  rts Je reçois une lettre
de General Motors qui dit s'il vous plaît
amenez votre véhicule chez le concessionnaire vous
pourriez avoir un problème alors pourquoi General
Motors me parle d'un problème dans mon
camion mais j'ai un produit dans mon corps
que les fabricants ne me font pas
savoir  les femmes avec des implants texturés dans
leur corps au Canada méritent une lettre
non pas pour les alarmer mais pour les alerter
qu'elles doivent commencer à rechercher les symptômes dont
elles ont besoin pour faire attention aux changements subtils les
fabricants Allergan et le
mentor ont refusé de nous accorder une entrevue
dans des déclarations écrites qu'ils  les deux ont déclaré que
la sécurité de leurs produits est
étayée par de nombreuses études réalisées
avant et après leur approbation, les
femmes de notre histoire qui avaient des
implants mammaires avaient ceci à dire à Santé
Canada semblent plus diversifiées là où la
pénurie de sécurité peut affecter les
rires rigides de notre Dumas.  m Edna a
Jessica ma immédiate vous avez besoin de cela ii
est un-- alors s'il vous plaît et famille immédiate
seule très
Université McCaskey conjoint FX est un plan
de c  onnects une poche peut présenter
quelque chose le président a vu quelque chose de plus
merdique mélodique suppose peut importer un
clavier personne de sexe masculin ce sera moi J tan
my pantsu cash cash cher Père Noël Canada
juste une camionnette plus vite plus Pierre stars
talkin et il avait la section couleur est un
très probablement mon
message poka familial sur les ambulanciers apparaît,
il met un pied ne signifie pas
dr.  Cohen tirhard vient de publier les
résultats d'une étude suivant 25 000
femmes l'étude conclut que les
porteuses d'implants ont un risque accru de
développer des maladies auto-immunes
il estime que des facteurs génétiques et
environnementaux prédisposent certaines
femmes à de tels problèmes à un certain moment
il faut décider de cette action  devrait être
prise et l'une des actions
est bien sûr que nous développons un excellent
test de risque pour définir qui va être malade,
mais jusqu'à ce que ce test ne soit pas encore là, nous
devrions conclure que les implants mammaires
ne sont pas sûrs, ces femmes n'exigent pas
que  tous les implants mammaires soient retirés
du marché ils veulent que les risques potentiels
associés aux implants soient
étudiés et divulgués de manière adéquate Je cherche
cette femme qui se fait opérer
demain pour en savoir plus que moi
discuter de la question du
lymphome afin que Terry reçoive l'
invitation qu'elle attendait après
tout, cela valait-il le déplacement
à un moment donné?  int vous devez avoir une certaine
foi en vous, vous investissez le temps que
vous investissez de l'argent et espérez le
meilleur, donc nous avons de l'espoir
[Musique]